i don't know i haven't seen anybody get
this card
so addy got some props though before you
ever see nobody get this phone
i wonder if i'll see anybody get any
further
back oh open back
there
is the farthest
attic
it
anybody from the demo today
yeah grab your shrine
beautiful right it is so it is so
cinematic the foreground thing that's
going on the black and white meal the
grass the animation
is absolutely stunning to see a team do
you know how big the dev
i don't know how many people worked on
this right uh
shout out to whoever
and i have how many heart into it yeah
this this is a do you know if they're
planning on like adding like more like
different modes different weapons or
anything like that and change it up a
little bit i don't
think i'm not aware of any plans to do
that kind of thing at this time uh-huh
armor guys
right now there's a different
difficulties oh yeah one bit of help
we look strong please
sorry if i just peeked good luck
good shot on
trek to yomi wall absolutely phenomenal
coming out this year coming out this
year can't tell you when yet can't tell
us when
but all major platforms everything
except switch on no switch for are we
launching
in game pass day and day
i do believe so yeah for gameplay and
playstation
phenomenal lord attic before you go real
quick to the people what's your thoughts
check the yomi i liked it i think it's
uh i think
camera's there sir
it kind of gives me like a seafood vibe
like where it's like that one i walk out
of it it's like a seafood okay yeah
except for uh i feel like this is harder
because like
you get a little like if you die you
just throw a hole like yeah if you die
you're going back to a
not fair enough
i like i like the artwork i wish i could
have gotten like a one on one
but you know they got people on the line
yeah i don't totally understand a little
directory on the y'all one of the most
highly anticipated titles an absolute
pleasure with all the digital in the
building salute this is the one to watch
out for